valentina buenos días como todo este año
2020 se vio tocado también por la
pandemia recordemos que en francia
estamos en un segundo confinamiento por
lo tanto estas ceremonias se realizaron
sin familiares y sin sobrevivientes de
estos atentados solamente la alcaldesa
de parís como tú mencionabas antes y el
primer ministro jan castex visitaron los
lugares escenarios de estos terribles
ataques en esta dejamos las terrazas los
restaurantes para terminar aquí detrás
mío en la sala de conciertos bataclán
donde sabemos murió la mayor cantidad de
gente 90 personas en todo caso las
autoridades en la alcaldesa de parís
envió una especie de salvoconducto a los
familiares que quieran acercarse a los
lugares por ejemplo para poner en flores
para pensar en sus familiares las
asociaciones por su parte se van a
reunir de manera virtual y hay una serie
de eventos online a través de la
televisión para conmemorar esta fecha
tan triste además cuando se cumplen
cinco años ya asia es erika y es que el
país en este momento ha vuelto a la
'alerta máxima' hace pocas semanas cuál
es la sensación que tienen los
residentes frente a la seguridad en
francia
claro a valentina hay preocupación lo
decíamos en la nota a los que son
víctimas y sobrevivientes están llevando
todo un proceso no es cierto de
reconstrucción y cada ataque cada
atentado terrorista nuevo que se produce
es para ellos una huida hacia atrás un
retroceder en este proceso de
reconstrucción personal la alerta
terrorista está elevada tanto dicen las
autoridades como en el año 2015 cuando
ocurrieron estos ataques terroristas
recordemos tres en un mes el atentado
contra samuel para ti el atentado de
niza y el que ocurrió en o lejos de aquí
en la antigua sede de charlie hebdo una
amenaza sobre todo que es endógena y un
estado que se ha visto de la sociedad
alterado por cosas como el proceso del
reality esto la republicación de las
caricaturas de mahoma y ese boicot que
hubo en los países musulmanes en contra
de france y del presidente manuel macro
por sus declaraciones en pos de la
libertad de expresión por lo tanto
obviamente y preocupación sobre todo en
las autoridades por esa amenaza interna
pero como tú mencionabas al comienzo
también por esa amenaza externa que
sigue existiendo recordemos el atentado
de viena fue reivindicada
por el grupo estado islámico y hoy
fuerte a un líder de al-qaeda en el time